in terms of preparing um
for
space flight
you know i i tweeted about this and i
joked about it and i i talked to you
along quite a lot these days
what i tweeted was i'd like to do a
podcast in space one day
and it was a silly thing
because i was thinking for some reason
in my mind i was thinking 10 20 years
from now and then i realized like
wait why not like now
yeah there's no
just even seeing what uh axiom is doing
what inspiration four is doing it's like
regular civilians could just start going
up
well so let me ask you this question
when do you think we saw jeff bezos go
on to orbit when you think elon goes up
to space
so
his thinking about this is it's
partially responsible until it's safe
because he has such a
direct engineering roles in the running
of multiple companies
so at which point do you think what's
your prediction for the year that elon
will go up
i think you probably go up by 2026
i would say
because the number of missions planned
there will be
several missions per year through
multiple space agencies and companies
that are really
making low earth orbit very routine
and by go up i think it might look for
example the inspiration for mission just
went up for three days in flight you
know and it was enough time to get up
there do some experiments enjoy the view
and then you came back the axiom
missions are a bit more complicated
there's docking you're up in the space
station it's a shared atmosphere so you
have to follow all the iss protocols
what's what's interesting about the
dragon capsule and the inspiration for
and some of these what are called free
flyer missions you can just launch into
space you basically have your own little
mini space station for a few days it's
not that big right but i think that's
what we'd probably see him do first
because they're fair they're you know
we're going to see a lot more tests of
those in the next three to three years
but they're
already already been demonstrated to be
safe and then you're not trying to go
for 10 to 20 days or months or years at
a time it's just up in space for a few
days but you're in proper space it's an
orbital flight it's not just a subwoofer
flight you're
you could do the podcast from there and
i think 2026 i wonder how the audio
works
see also can you comment on 2026 i'll
start getting ready
i'll start pushing him on this i'm quite
quite serious it's a fascinating kind of
axiom two still has room you could go on
that mission if you wanted it so i'll
ask you about axiom um
what
how strict are these
so
this this seems surreal that civilians
are traveling up so
how many how much bureaucracy is there
still in your experience for the
scientific i mean i know it's a
difficult question to ask a scientist
because you get to you know you don't
want to complain too much
but
how much you know there's sometimes
bureaucracy with nsf and the od and the
funding and all those kinds of things
um
that kind of prevent you from
being as free as you might sometimes
like to to do all kinds of wild
experiments and crazy experiments now
the benefit
of that is that you don't do any wild
and crazy experiments that hurt people
right and so it's very important to put
safety first but it's like a dance a
little too much restrictions the
bureaucracy can hamper the flourishing
of science a little too little of that
can get some crazy scientists to start
doing unethical experiments okay that
said nasa and just space flight in
general is
sort of
famously very uh very uh risk-averse
yeah so what's your sense currently
about like
even like doing a podcast
right podcast you know unless it's a you
know i think with uh
mixed martial arts is a pretty safe
activity unless you're doing a the
octagon version of your podcast i mean
just getting there and back is the only
real risky part which is still risky
right but i think you're not asking to
do you know open heart surgery in space
you're just saying what if i do a
podcast and i think well fun you're
trying to ask to have fun yes and i feel
like fun sounds dangerous any kind of
fun
that's what's been extraordinary is that
traditionally yes i think
most the space agencies have been very
by definition bureaucratic because
they're coming from the government
and but they've been been that way for a
really good reason is that safety
you know in the early 60s we know almost
nothing about the body in space
except for you know some of the work
that pilots had done at really high
altitudes so we really didn't know what
at all to expect so it's good that there
were decades of resolute focus on just
safety
but now we know it's pretty safe we know
this physiological response responses we
know what to expect we can also treat
some of it but hopefully hopefully soon
we'll treat a lot more of it
but
if you just want to go up there it's
actually now it's just a question of
cost like imagine
i think the way you can view a lot of
the commercial space flight companies is
that if you have the funds you can
basically plan the mission all the
training they'll do is to help you get
prepared for how you run some of the
instrumentation how you can fly the
rocket to the limited degree and how to
use some of the equipment but
fundamentally it's no longer a question
of you know years and years of training
and selection this impossible odds task
of becoming an astronaut
it's frankly just a question of funds
expensive plane rides so how much how
much you mention axiom well is it known
how much the it costs
for the plane ride there is no official
number and it depends on the mission of
course so the if you ask them well often
they'll say well how serious are you
they really want they don't just want to
give out random numbers to people right
but the numbers of because for example
we propose one mission
we want a new twin study where someone
goes up and stays up there for 500 to
550 days but to basically be up there
for the longest time ever to simulate
the time it would take to get to mars
and back for the shortest possible
duration about 550 days because if you
went there and immediately turned around
you could maybe make that mission
otherwise it's a three-year mission
the
and there we go you know it's you're
looking at the ranges of you know it's
50 to 100 million dollars in that
ballpark range but the reason it's so
variable is it depends what are you
doing up there if you're up there for
example for two two years basically
almost almost two years
that's a long time just being one spot
right so could you be doing some things
where you're yeah it's you can your time
is valuable so you do experiments and
people pay for those and that defrays
the cost or you could build something or
you could do podcasts and maybe you know
fundraise on the podcast and so as long
as you the reason the cost is variable
is because it depends well
do you have all the money and you say i
want to go and just sit in space for two
years and do nothing well then you have
to pay for all that time that you're up
there if you want to do things and yeah
i see the the official x1 mission
was 55 million for a trip to the iss
it could be worse
wait i uh sergey just posted a 35 000
price tag per night per person on the
iss is that real
i don't know that sounds about right
that's why that's like a real hotel so
to stay
oh so interesting
um
and then i'm sure there's costs with the
docking and all those kinds of things
that's from the perspective of axiom the
private company or spacex or whoever's
whoever is paying the cost and
uh in the short term in in the long term
yeah
and then think about a lot of that cost
is rocket fuel a lot of is the ride so
it's i've been on calls where axioms
like hey spacex give us make it a little
cheaper we can make it cheaper in our
and if it's that